Congress getting tough on the rise in
anti-Semitism on our nation's campuses
liberal universities becoming cesspools
of pramas hatred and today the
presidents of three major universities
Harvard upen and MIT three schools I
never applied to had to explain to
lawmakers why they haven't reigned in
radical anti-israeli students who've
made life a living nightmare for Jewish
students 73% of whom say that they've
experienced or seen anti-Semitism on
campus our University revered for its
pursuit of knowledge has devolved into
an arena where Jewish students tiptoe
through their days uncertain and unsafe
unmistakable anti-Semitism that I have
experienced on campus is reminiscent of
the Jew hatred I've heard about from my
grandparents Holocaust Survivors this is
not just harassment this is our lives on
the line the most heated moment New York
congresswoman Elise stonic pressing
Harvard's president about the calls for
genocide against Jews which took place
on her campus you understand that the
use of the term inata in the context of
the Israeli Arab conflict is indeed a
call for violent armed resistance do you
believe that type of hateful speech is
contrary to Harvard's code of conduct or
is it allowed at Harvard it is at odds
with the values of Harvard can you not
say here that it is against the code of
conduct at Harvard we Embrace a
commitment to free expression what
action has been taken against students
who are harassing and calling for the
genocide of Jews on Harvard's campus I
can assure you we have
robust have been taken I'm not asking
underway how did you think the president
of Harvard came across at the hearing
today Dana like she had been overly
prepared by
lawyers and is concerned about backlash
on her campus if she were to just simply
answer the question
about the genocide of Jews with if that
is bullying and harassment I think the
only answer to that is yes yes and as
Larry summer said there's been a double
standard in the way these University
leaders respond to racism right so other
forms of prejudice we know how that's
gone we know even for example the
president and the vice president any
hint of racism they'll be out there on
camera interviews they'll be out there
doing a press conference all this white
house has done I mean I'm not saying
that there are for anti-Semitism of
course not but is it too much to ask for
the president of the United States to do
an on camera statement about this he's
doing a lot of fundraisers this week and
great go for it I know you want to run
for re-election and have enough
resources to do that but there are those
students today we were the only Network
that took those students live their
press their press conference today and
I'm so glad we did very impressive young
people and their pain is real they're
saying like we are actually concerned
about our safety and they were
representing their other students the
other thing is they can't get their
education the the classes are
interrupted they have to walk through
all these protests in order to get from
one part of the school to the other we
had this other G on today Noah Fay from
Columbia University she's a brave young
woman she's the ra the resident
assistant um manager for her dorm she
has vandalism on her door on her board
on they are dealing with so much and it
would not hurt the campus presidents or
even our president to say something to
them they're asking for it it's the
first time I've felt bad for an
RA
Jessica I thought the students were
fantastic I can't imagine being able to
express myself so clearly and about a
subject so difficult at that age and I
struggle turn I'm turning 40 with issues
that are so personal to me now um so
kudos to them and for standing up for
themselves
I'm noticing um amongst my friends um
fellow Jews who went to a lot of these
Ivy League schools my taex messages are
full of a lot of remorse and what are we
going to do right by the time that our
kids are getting ready to to go to
school hopefully we will not have
forgotten this as well that this is how
the administration responded to these
kinds of things um I am surprised that
there hasn't even been and I know it's
the most base level but a bit of a
reversal when they're seeing the dollars
pour out the door because people are
going to continue to do this and more
and more people are going to say I'm not
you're not getting my donation Dana had
um one of the biggest donors to upen on
this morning on America's Newsroom who I
thought um was really interesting and
the point that he highlighted that I
think is important to call out again is
that this is not a new thing that
foreign dollars have been coming into
American universities for a very long
time and it's not just to put up
buildings but it's to change the culture
and the way that people think about
Israel um and Jew RIT large around the
world and I wanted to tell everyone as
well to take a look at Bill Amman who
founded um Persian Capital um
billionaire investor he published his
second letter that he sent to Dr Gay the
president of Harvard she did not respond
to the first one um noting in it that
Harvard actually ranks in the bottom 25%
in terms of the Free Speech rankings and
he spoke to a bunch of Faculty members
who didn't use their names because they
want to keep their jobs which makes
sense but some quotes um years ago
Harvard stopping a place where all
perspectives were welcome and then he
asked about why this was different than
another other Middle East conflicts
because we know it's going on constantly
and one of the professors said Israel is
the rare case where we have a hot
conflict between people that are deemed
white versus people of color and I have
been resistant um to buy into the
argument that this is about race and
that there it is impossible to people to
see white people as victims but as more
of this footage comes out out of the
rapes as Greg says sexual atrocities um
that were committed by Hamas I I don't
know how people can look themselves in
the mirror and not call this explicitly
what it is when you see the gang rapes
the child rapes the death and
destruction reaped by Hamas yeah how big
of an issue is the racial component to
this conflict I think I think I what
Jessica's saying is kind of a
realization that
you are no longer considered a
marginalized group you are considered
part of the white oppressor and when
that happens everything is permissible
even laughing or mocking a sexual
atrocity you know there is a pro
Palestinian side that makes a sound
argument me know being critical of
Israel doesn't make you anti-semitic but
that's not the argument anyone's making
on the street or on campus we could be
critical of Israel the same way we can
be critical of France or Germany that
that isn't what's happening here it's
the refusal to accept the sexual
atrocity despite mountains mountains of
evidence you know and that any country
that falls victim of that has a right to
respond if let's say if you just if
you're talking to a protester I always
try to figure out how do you talk to
them take Israel and Palestine out of
this you walk into a room and there's a
gang of young men raping and then
murdering a helpless female do you
suddenly add his historical context to
that and over time do you then bring in
nuance and debate over the troubled
relationships maybe her parents or
grandparents had with those guys parents
it's like no you don't you punish those
people you have to keep throwing this in
their face SE this is a sexual atrocity
there's no historical context for it as
for the college President she's so gay
Dr gay yes Dr Gay Harvard president
judge Janine take us home you know what
it reminds me of is you know if you
prosecute you know for murder or a
sexual violence never ever does a
defense attorney come in and say well
you know there was always bad blood
there there is justification in the
penal law for this I mean this is a
whole new upside down way of thinking
that is bizarre and is not consistent
with what a civilized society does and
acts I have a couple of thoughts number
one uh it's very interesting we've heard
for years that s that that that speech
is violence and uh you know whenever a
conservative speaks it's violence we got
to shut them down we can't allow them to
speak and now all of a sudden speech
that promotes violence is protected
speech so I I came out after reading the
segment uh uh the the paperwork and I
said what was the point of this hearing
was it a hearing where everybody just
comes out and says you're bad and and
we're good we don't want want to
tolerate it unless Congress comes up
with legislation or does something that
that punishes this kind of behavior
there was no point to all of this other
than a dog and pony show that we see
every day in Congress now rest assured
that even Harvard the University of
Pennsylvania and these uh Ivy schools
get federal grants they get Federal
contracts they get tax breaks why should
the American people be subsidizing any
of these schools if there are Jewish
students girls and boys young men young
women who are afraid to go to class
afraid because they might be either
raped or assaulted because of who they
are that is a hate crime and you forget
about the these universities saying
we're going to cut back the amount you
need to give in order to be an important
donor no you take away the federal
benefits and you shut them down okay up
next a bad sign for Democrats KL merch
is not selling hey Sean Hannity here hey
click here to subscribe to Fox News
YouTube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere
else